multiplica 5 a 2 por 4 a cuadrada más 3
a menos 1 entonces estamos multiplicando
un binomio con un trinomio por lo tanto
esta herramienta foil no va a servir hoy
nada más sirve cuando estamos
multiplicando binomio con binomio así
que vamos a tener que utilizar la ley
distributiva vamos a distribuir este
trinomio 4a cuadrada más 3 a menos 1 en
estos dos términos entonces vamos a
multiplicar primero este con este y
luego vamos a multiplicar vamos a
multiplicar el trinomio con el menos dos
déjame ponerlo que queda aquí abajo
multiplicando 5 a con el trinomio es 5
ha multiplicado por 4 a cuadrada más 3 a
menos 1 y ahora vamos con el segundo la
segunda multiplicación es más le voy a
poner así más menos 2 por x 4 a cuadrada
más 3 a menos 1 muy bien ahora lo que
sigue es distribuir este 5 a en estos
tres términos y este menos 2 en estos
tres voy a hacer eso
cuanto me queda esta multiplicación 5
por 4 es 20
no podemos pensar como a la 1 a la 1 x
es al cubo sumamos los exponentes más 5
por 3 15 a 4 por aesa cuadrada menos y 5
a por menos 1 es 5 a ok ahora vamos con
esta parte de acá vamos a ver qué nos
queda menos 2 por 4 a cuadrada es menos
ocho al cuadrado menos dos por tres
es menos seis a y menos dos por menos
uno menos por menos es más
entonces nos queda más 2 ahora tenemos
que simplificar algunas cosas porque
tenemos términos de igual grado por
ejemplo bueno este de aquí no verdad
esté aquí está solito el 20 al cubo pues
no hay ningún otro al cubo entonces lo
escribimos así 20 a alguno
pero por ejemplo este 15 a cuadrada
tiene este menos 8 a cuadrada
si tenemos 15 de algo y le restamos 8
nos quedan siete más 7
cuadrada entonces serían este de acá y
este de acá vale ahora vamos con a con a
que tenemos pues tenemos este menos 5 a
y a menos 5 estamos restando 6 menos 5
6 - 11 menos 11
y finalmente aquí hay un 2 y s2 pues es
nada más un término constante que no nos
que no tiene nadie más entonces es más 2
muy bien con esto ya terminamos la
multiplicación ya simplificamos pero
vamos a ver otra forma de hacerlo que es
un poco análoga a como multiplicamos los
números va entonces vamos a hacer esa
multiplicación aquí abajito y la idea es
ir poniendo estas cosas con cuidado a
qué me refiero mira ponemos el 4 a
cuadrada más tres menos uno el trinomio
aquí 4a
cuadrada más tres a menos uno va y voy a
multiplicar por 5 a 2
pero ese 5 a menos 2 lo voy a poner en
el lugar que le corresponde es decir el
5 lo voy a poner aquí en este lugar que
es como el lugar de el exponente 1 para
entonces le voy a poner aquí 5
y el menos dos lo voy a poner aquí menos
2 va y lo que vamos a hacer es esta
multiplicación
en realidad es muy similar a como cuando
hacemos multiplicaciones con numeritos o
sea aquí tenemos el lugar de a a la 0
aquí tenemos el lugar de a la 1 y aquí
tenemos el lugar de a a la 2 no tenemos
unidades decenas y centenas pero tenemos
potencias de a entonces con esa idea
vamos a realizar nuestra multiplicación
a ver qué nos queda vamos con este menos
2 déjame marcarlo con este color rojo
entonces menos 2 vamos a multiplicarlo
por cada uno de estos términos menos 2 x
menos uno menos por menos es más nos
queda 2 donde lo ponemos pues en el
lugar de donde no hay hasta donde está a
la 0 hay 2 ahora menos dos por tres
es menos 6 a como tiene y lo ponemos en
esta columna que es la columna de las as
entonces nos quedan menos 6
luego menos dos por cuatro a cuadrada es
menos ocho a cuadrada y de modo similar
lo ponemos aquí menos ocho a cuadrada
ahora vamos con el 5a
con el 5 a misma idea 5 a x menos uno es
menos 5 a donde ponemos eso pues en la
columna de las hadas menos 5 a 5 a por 3
a 15 al cuadrado lo ponemos aquí 15 a
cuadrada más 15 al cuadrado y finalmente
5 a por 4 a cuadrada es 20 a kubica 20 a
kubica déjame a bajar tantito está y
realizamos la suma va entonces sumando
que nos queda nos queda este 2 no lo
sumamos con nada es nada más un 2 menos
65 a es menos 11 a más 2 va luego 15 a
menos 8 15 a cuadrada menos 8 a cuadrada
es 7 cuadrada 15 menos 87 y finalmente
pues este 20 acumuló tenemos que sumar
lo con nada y lo dejamos como 20
kubica muy bien entonces está muy padre
esto obtuvimos la misma respuesta y
bueno esto es porque básicamente hicimos
lo mismo aquí estamos aprovechando la
ley distributiva pero se ve un poco más
bonito entonces estamos haciendo
exactamente lo mismo nada más que lo
escribimos un poco distinto